so there are a whole bunch of different
interesting senate races to follow we've
been following
many of them and one of them is horrible
horrible senator
lindsey graham a republican from south
carolina lindsay's been in the senate
since 2003 he won in 2002
entered the senate in january of 2003
he's up for re-election
he has a solid challenger in democrat
jamie harrison now the latest ad from
lindsey graham's campaign
has taken jamie harrison's skin
harrison's black
and darkened it which is something we've
seen republicans do
it's it all it they it never gets
lightened somehow
it's every time we see one of these
things where a black candidate or
politician
has their skin tone modified in an ad
it's never lighter it's always darker
and indeed that's what happened here
uh this sometimes happened to barack
obama by the way you might remember so
in this ad which we're showing
our video audience a real picture of
jamie harrison on the left
the altered picture on the right the ad
looks to tie
jamie harrison to comedian kathy griffin
i guess it's bad if kathy griffin
supports you in south carolina maybe i
don't know among republican circles
but the most notable thing is the
digital alteration of harrison's skin
tone the graham campaign says
you know this wasn't actually about
making harrison look more black it was
just we we used an effect
on the ad we use the same effect on
lindsey graham's face in another ad
i don't know exactly where and this is a
total
non-story they say meanwhile
in another totally coincidental
accident just a mistake someone made a
republican senator published an
ad where his jewish opponent's nose was
enlarged
georgia republic it sounds insane i know
georgia republican senator david perdue
has an opponent
his opponent is 33 year old john ossoff
ossoff happens to be jewish a classic
anti-semitic trope is
the big-nosed or hook-nosed jew the
purdue campaign published an
ad to facebook where john ossoff's nose
i mean
can you believe this was digitally
enlarged
and by the way done not super
professionally ocef's nose
is enlarged but it also just looks weird
and adding to this the ad includes a
picture of senator chuck schumer who
also happens to be jewish
but is a senator from new york has
nothing to do with that race and it
includes the tagline
democrats are trying to buy georgia
of course playing up anti-semitic tropes
about
jews and money with the big nose and
everything
the purdue campaign was confronted about
this they said oh
yeah that modification they're calling
the
enhanced nose size a modification
the modification was made without their
authorization
because of an error that a vendor they
work with
made so i guess blaming it on
whoever they hired to make the ad now
is it believable at all that a vendor
would do this
and even like without the nose
enlargement that's only slightly better
they're still
including chuck schumer for some reason
and talking about democrats
buying stuff both of the democrats
pictured
happen to be jewish it's it's very
difficult to imagine that this is an
accident
but i guess that's the way they're
playing it now as a preempt
because there are going to be you know
every time we talk about this people
write in they say david
republicans aren't anti-semitic it's the
republicans that
support israel whether while democrats
don't or support israel to a lesser
degree
i i don't know if these are bad faith
actors or they're just ignorant
republicans love israel because they
believe
israel needs to be in jewish hands for
jesus to return
okay there's a huge evangelical
christian movement
that loves israel not because they
understand
and care about or or whatever uh
thousands of years of jewish oppression
it's because they think it'll bring
jesus
back they don't actually care about jews
as people
certainly not american jews who
overwhelmingly
vote for democrats and remember israel
and american jews are two completely
separate and different things
republicans
care about the land of israel for bogus
religious reasons
sometimes for political reasons it's not
about
fighting anti-semitism or anything like
it it's truly horrifying
that this is what we're dealing with
right now and all of these people need
to be removed
it's not looking great for david uh for
for awesome john ossoff running against
david perdue i the polling is not great
uh the polling is not fantastic for
jamie harrison
against lindsey graham in south carolina
but let's remove at least
some of these people in november i hope
that we will and
some republicans are going down i just
don't know whether it's these two but
fight every race do everything we can